elle a frôé les icebergs et les baleines
j'ai eu envie de vivre une aventure
forte avec l'océan en étant à 30 cm de
la surface de l'eau m de Fontenois est
arrivé ce matin à La Corogne en Espagne
elle est la première femme à traverser
l'Atlantique en ce sens à la rame et de
prouver que c'était possible pour une
femme de réaliser ce type d'aventure
parce que c'était injustement réservé
aux hommes elle est la première femme à
avoir traversé l'Atlantique à la rame
d'Ouest en Est mot de fonir c'était le 9
octobre
[Musique]
2003 20 ans plus tard elle témoigne pour
Lina faut quand même savoir que la
réalisation d'un projet déjà tu as la
99,9 % des gens qui te disent que tu es
complètement dingo qui ne crois pas en
toi ils te disent que tu y arriveras
jamais que c'est dangereux que c'est pas
possible que vois pas l'intérêt donc tu
dois vivre aussi avec ce poids ce poids
de l'autre à côté de toi qui te
décourage du matin au soir et puis après
tu as les contraintes vraiment
matérielles qui sont bah comment je
trouve un bateau comment je le construis
et comment je trouve l'argent et donc
oui j'ai dû emprunter de l'argent pour
ce défi mot de fonois a été inspiré par
Gérard
d'oville premier Français à avoir
traversé l'Atlantique à la rame en
1980 que ressentez-vous à l'approche de
Brest
je ressens pas grandchose he depuis 2 TR
jours parce que je réalise pas
tellementin j'ai rencontré Gérard
abeville un jour sur un salon noutique
et je me suis dit il a l'air quand même
dans leement normal et je me suis dit
comment est-ce qu'un humain tout à fait
normal et vraiment qui me ressemble avec
de bras de jambes voilà comment on peut
se dire qu'on veut un jour traverser un
océan et surtout qu'on y arrive il y a
quelque chose de fascinant j'aimais bien
vraiment cette disparité entre
l'extraordinaire grandeur d'un défi la
difficulté que ça peut représenter face
au 40e ou ou au vagu de 10 m de haut
enfin et puis la fragilité d'un humain
ma de Fontenois est parti le 13 juin
2003 de Saint-Pierre et miclon la météo
est capricieuse je je comptais partir
sereine hier déjà j'ai eu un petit peu
d'affaement quand Météo France V voir en
courant pour me dire que que l' temps
avait changé jour du départ on se sent
seul on se sent intimidé face à l'océan
on se sent vulnéraable et puis on est
face à un inconnu on se dit est-ce que
j'ai pas est-ce que j'ai pas vu trop
grand euh là j'ai un peu le stress je
pensais sincèrement que que ça serait
mieux je me disais mais c'est pas vrai
quoi si jamais j'abandonne au bout d'une
heure au bout de 2 jours mais je vais
passer pour qui je me souviens qu'il y
avait certains qui pariaaient en disant
le nombre de jours que j'allais durer en
mer qui disait ouais alors la petite là
allez combien tu dis toi de jours allez
non 3IS 2 jours après son départ
l'aventurière a dû ramer contre des
vents de face mettant le cap sur le sud
pour éviter tout iceberg et rencontrer
au plus vite le golf stream mais elle
n'a pu éviter la tempête hier son bateau
a chaviré mais la jeune femme s'accroche
les mains couvertes d'ampoules et
l'estomac totalement retourné devant
elle reste 97 % du parcours à effectuer
quand on est seul en mer on est vraiment
dans le rythme de la nature dans le
rythme des océans on est avec le rythme
du soleil
on se base au rythme de la météo donc on
va ramer 8 à 10 he par jour ensuite on
fait des pauses alors moi j'entretenais
beaucoup pour éviter d'avoir des escars
je me massais les mains les jambes les
fesses enfin tu vois parce que du coup
tu rames quand même position assise ton
bateau il est quand même minuscule tu
peux à peine te tenir debout et tu peux
encore moins mettre un pied devant
l'autre faut quand même imaginer que
pendant 5 mois tu ne mets pas un pied
devant l'autre tu ne marches pas durant
la traversée la navigatrice a connu
quelques imprévus après 98 jours de mer
alors qu'elle espè et enfin trouvé des
vents favorables son désalinisateur
tombe en panne oui alors le problème de
désalinisateur c'est vrai que c'était
hallucinant d'un seul coup tu as plus
d'eau à boire c'est vrai que ça paraît
inconcevable à 8 jours du but la
française ne dispose plus que de 8 L
d'eau douce alors que sa consommation
est estimé à 2 l par jour dès lors il
n'est plus question de record mais de
survie tuta es au milieu de ta tempête
avec ton machin et alors du coup j'avais
des pièce pour un deuxième
dstanilisateur donc j'ai bu mon urine
donc j'ai fait ça pendant 5 jours j'ai
réussi à faire avec des pièces détachées
refaire un des salinisateurs enfin bref
et repartir le 9 octobre 2003 après 119
jours en mer et 6700 km parcourus ça y
est ma de fonenix atteint la Corogne en
Espagne j'avais envie de prouver qu'une
femme pouvait tout aussi bien y arver
qu'un homme que c'était pas qu'une
question de gros bras et que même toute
jeune fille qu'on qu'on peut être on
peut aussi avoir envie de se lancer des
défis comme ça extrême je voulais
montrer aux femmes voilà que que c'est
que c'est d'abord dans la tête qu'on
fait les choses que c'est d'abord avec
ta volonté qu'on fait les choses et que
si tu as envie de graper une montagne
traverser un océan à l'Arab enfin peu
importe moi j'avais envie de vivre ça
parce que j'aime la mer et parce que
c'est vraiment l'environnement dans
lequel je me sens le mieux mais ça
permet peut-être de faire passer un
message plus largement et j'ai reçu
beaucoup de courriers dans ce sens avec
des femmes qui ah bah grâce à vous j'ai
réalisé mon rêve de de partir ici de
changer de métier de voilà de de de
croire en
[Musique]
elle